and it has begun the descent of left go
the ascent of sims a balance of power
and the third wheel is back Josh
vendrick in his 1942 polo shirt hey
older generations
oh you want to come at my sweater I am
drunk I am a bum I do live in a trailer
with my mom I do em do em dammit dammit
I was goin eight mile oh I was gonna
come at my own switch it's in your theme
of Captain Spock eNOS I've got to mister
we're travelling back into time and
we're gonna review left goes shitbirds
from last week and see what he did wrong
let me see your pants stand up I'm just
wearing maroon jog oh my gosh it's
maroon on maroon yeah with gosh damn
with my see your feet they're so
camouflage I don't even see you see that
on camera
[Music]
flexible enough tight groin alright guys
I hope you've enjoyed the Sims left go
show that comes out Wednesdays hope you
enjoyed the film room episode I know
that it was a lot more conversations but
Sims his buddy Michael Lombardo wanted
to come on and my time I had a more Mike
metaphor Mike any time I can hear you
and him going back and forth you guys
have really good football conversation
we do your two humans that are willing
to disagree with each other yeah
actually still listen yeah I think his
rare right well I think we're two guys
that I mean of course he is so
knowledgeable and has way more
experience with brainiac's and the NFL
than even I do but yeah I think he knows
that we both have a passion for the
sport yeah I do study and that he I
think listens to me from time to time
Josh didn't want to come on the betting
show today I told him I needed him I
want him to be the bank I'll be the bank
it's fine geez whatever you guys why
weren't you here last Wednesday or
Thursday I don't know no I was here last
year
oh yeah you were right okay member you
were saying Josh I want to bet this yes
it's all blurring together though I am I
cannot wait I have no work tomorrow Josh
how did Chris do last week Josh josh
Josh Josh how are your in-laws how are
they
delicious I don't know if they listen as
often because they're not in the car as
much but they do listen okay that's good
I just wanted Chris guys last week was
not good it was not good at all record
all right so the door records first last
week Chris went six and nine against the
spread that's okay yep Adam not good
three and twelve whoa what were the
three I got right the three you got
right so you both got Cleveland plus
eight and a half gosh left go you picked
Jacksonville plus one and a half so I
got Jacksonville and then you guys both
got Chicago minus three other than that
other than that everything was wrong
Green Bay Minnesota was a pick'em that
gets scrapped yeah I don't know how that
works
Oh Hickam so what you're kind of picking
a team and they tie tied so like a loss
I know what is that now it's a push you
like it should be a loss you have to pay
the what do they call the big the big
right I don't know because the bookie
and I'm scrapping it from the right yeah
you ended up getting that game though in
your pick and play did I me and my
brother are doing the three two one pool
again and we had Minnesota plus one so
the top one yeah so I was sitting with
let go when when Thielen caught that
pass I like threw a chair over double
throw because he helped our fantasy did
yeah we do all right so sim six and nine
left go three and twelve so Sims you
lost 300 bleacher bucks left very okay
day yeah left go you lost 1295 bucks so
coming out a weak one Sims your bank
account was at minus 80 left go yours
was plus 900 where are we now Sims you
are now - 380 left go you are - 390
negative but Sims you are up by $10 yeah
I did it for the entertainment good I
did it so we're neck-and-neck don't lie
you gotta work on that stop it stop
lying you didn't do all so nothing is
safe with good
so first game we're gonna pick games
today like with the scores yes with the
scores cuz I do I wonder how I picked in
my games like I don't have any record of
that as I said it was gonna care about
the spreads in the bank accounts so you
think you could do that in your
spreadsheets you have a lot of them I do
have a
lot of spreadsheets this is a
particularly good one maybe I could I
could share the spreadsheet with
everyone and just did you just see
yourself give yourself a blue steel look
into the camera he literally just like
did this I was taking a front picture
with somebody and then they were like ah
here's the camera and I literally like
made a pose they're like what did you
just do to your eyebrow yeah looks like
you're blue steel look it's like how
people like used to go out and then
before the nightclub back you're like in
the early days you ever see like your
friends do that where they're like they
got their you know Club yeah it's been
on their hairs all public post and they
give that squint into the mirror like
that Melania Trump like squint like if I
the people that go to the Roxbury
she's like a true squinter though like
yeah it's like let me look at myself
fuzzy in the mirror cause it's better
buzzing smizing it's amazing that's when
you smile with your eyes alright first
game we're doing here guys you previewed
it on me you previewed it on the
Thursday podcast Thursday Night Football
Jets at the Browns Cleveland a three
point favorite looking for their first
win of the season
let's get your bets here first so Sims
how did you pick this one well do you
want me to come out and get my breakdown
first so you don't have to right away
you gave your breakdown yesterday so
just tell us how you I'm going $10 on
the Cleveland Browns I think they get
off the schnide here on this win okay I
just worry about I'm at the point where
I really don't know who to pick in this
Thursday night game I'm picking the home
team and the fact the home team for two
straight we write and the fact that the
away team is playing is a rookie
quarterback and this Cleveland defense
is the real deal yes oh they are so this
is this is one of the best defenses in
the sport and this will be them to this
point in Sam Donald's career the most
Jim mental gymnastics that he has had a
deal and you're going against Ali with
this pick yes I I don't want to walk to
the newsstand with you next week with
Ali when he loses hi segment
I am the I this one to me is such a true
coin flip yeah I look at it and I go I
could totally see miles Garrett all over
Sam darn 'old
I think the way that this game was gonna
go is Cleveland's gonna get to him early
and instead of throwing an interception
in the first quarter like he's done the
last two weeks I think he has a big
thumb
in the first quarter and Fox is gonna
put up a graphic about Sam Darnell
turnovers early in games it's kind of
just how I see that and then this new
field goal kicker comes out and I think
he actually hits one Greg Joseph I think
his name is I kind of looked at it I am
going with Ally
I'm going with the Jets because I'm just
gonna trust Ally at this point I'm gonna
go $100 on the Jets actually I like that
they have four former Browns yeah I like
that they have Crowell prior screen in
mcallen I think that you know they're in
the locker room going let's kick these
guys ass that's a little bit means a
little bit more this Greg Joseph kid the
kicker he went three for three for Miami
and the preseason that was just I wanted
to see did he ever make kicks before
yeah I just I think the Jets are gonna
win this game with into the better team
they are five and OH in their last five
games against Cleveland to give you some
of that stuff yeah eight three and one
against the spread in their last 12
games as underdogs of three or more I
think the Jets are one of those teams
that I think Todd Bowles likes his team
being an underdog yeah but I could see
this going either way I think at the end
of the game your point rookie on a short
week against a good defense we're gonna
leave this game going damn Sam darn 'old
it's not your average rookie no III
think that's what scares me about the
game almost more than I think first so
I'm gonna pick the Browns to win the
game 22 17 okay that's my score I'll be
a push it would be a push but the other
thing I'll say this this is what scares
me about Cleveland and there's another
team I'll talk about today too
Tyrod Taylor does not turn the ball over
at home great that's great he also
doesn't play to win the games he plays
not to lose and we have to stop he's got
to stop doing that we got a play dough
you gotta play to win the teams that win
have quarterbacks that make plays like
in the explosive plays Department like
we talked about a lot you can't always
go well I didn't turn over the ball I
kept us in good positions though at some
point you have to make plays to help
your team win the game agree not play
not to lose let's move on let's get to
Sunday first game in the one o'clock the
Saints at the Falcons New Orleans coming
off a 21 18 win against the Browns the
Falcons coming off a 31 24 loss against
the Panthers spread in this game Saints
sorry Falcons - 3 yep and let go we're
gonna come first to you on this one this
is one where I looked at the teams
when I wrote down I think the Saints are
gonna win and then I dove into stuff
more and I typically don't want to do
that because I'm thinking I'm like look
man Dionne Jones is out Keanu Neal's out
but they did okay with it laughs but the
Saints are a much better offense in the
Panthers about that you lose a guard oh
then I look at the Falcons and I go okay
no Devonta Freeman I mean the Falcons
I've already talked about yeah that's
very good
the Falcons they're just really good
against the Saints when you really look
at the history of these two teams
especially in Atlanta last four times in
Atlanta Atlanta is 3 and 1 the Saints
are one in five in their last six road
games against NFC South teams so the
Saints are one of those teams that when
they play other teams and other
divisions
Sean Payton can kind of go off but when
they face teams that they face a lot
I think these teams kind of know what
the Saints want to do right so they're
one in five this is against the Panthers
the Bucs
and the Falcons on the road also I went
back in their first row game of the year
the Saints have not won since 2013 damn
so they haven't won their first row game
in like five years
I think the Saints are definitely gonna
be desperate I know the Falcons are
coming off of a win I expect both
offenses typically it's been a
low-scoring game yeah I think Michael
Thomas continues to do big things but
I'm siding here with the home team okay
and I'm siding with Julio Jones going
off because I just haven't seen the same
stuff out of Lattimore I'm going with
the Falcons here I'm gonna do $100 on
Atlanta okay um could totally see the
Saints winning this game but there's
just something about Atlanta in Atlanta
against the Saints that the NFC South
really does hold up those like trends
those trends yeah I get you this is it
is a coin flip game for me as well
I there's a lot of things to scare me I
wish I haven't seen the Saints game on
film last week on a defensive side of
the ball against the Cleveland Browns
which I wish I could say I saw that but
I haven't been able to really break that
down yet I'm hoping to do that today or
tomorrow but the thing that I listen I
do think the New Orleans Saints offense
of course can be surgical against this
Atlanta defense I do the one thing I
worry about with the New Orleans a
little bit
of late is you know I'm not concerned
but I do think Drew bleep drew brees has
maybe lost a mile per hour to on his
fastball
I really do there was a few throws last
week in the game that I just went damn
like that was there to be had like he's
got a he's got a step on the gas I feel
like it's all Thomas and all Camaro it
really is to this point they hasn't been
the spread around Saints offense has not
and they've not been able to run the
ball with the same effectiveness so in
Mark Ingram is real no doubt okay okay
so it's okay don't worry so either way I
think those are things I look at I don't
know I'm just going with a gut here this
is something that if I had real money on
I would never bet I am going to take the
Saints for $100 I just feel like play
that one more time
[Music]
you were frozen when that music came on
you no idea what to do I didn't know
because I was because if you think about
it jazz would be the music that Sims
would rather listen to because he likes
structure yep like jazz is like all over
the prize you're so right about jazz no
you really never understand jack he
always like even some good movies about
jazz I'm just like I don't really get
what they like about this it's cool that
they play the instruments and they're
amazing at it they go for 25 minutes and
they just like damn it just sounds like
a bunch of people play an inch I will
say this I have been to many jazz clubs
in the West Village right it was like
dates back of the day or just to go yeah
and they're the funny thing about jazz
you don't know if it's good or if it's
bad you're relying on everybody else to
see if they're feeling it right but
there's times where someone's like
Ximena bop Boop buddy buddy bop ba buddy
but a beat beat and I'm like I don't
know if this is good or bad but everyone
in here I love it I love it and I'm like
you nailed that kill um wait last thing
about that game too I will say this last
week
the Falcons offense went through the run
game you know I don't know if I could
sit here and say that they're gonna be
able to run the ball with the same
effect in my second question that gets
the Saints defense
what is the Saints defense right now
perspective it's a little all over the
place I feel like they're kind of like a
work in progress and trying to they
didn't play as much man-to-man it didn't
look like to me last
they mixed up coverages we're in week
one that was my complaint it was way too
much that my question is Kevin Coleman
gonna be able to run on the outside
that's their running game
I haven't Coleman on the edge it would
certainly was last week and I do I think
that still the Saints are a physical
bunch up front I would have a hard time
thinking they're gonna run the ball with
the same success as last week and I'm
still my bottom line is I'm just going
with Sean Payton I get it over Dan Quinn
in that group that's all it's really
what I really miss I was good I put on
hundred dollars truly a coin flip when
flip I would never touch it with real
money I'm picking the Saints to win 22
17 all right before we get to Green Bay
at Washington tweet just came in Tom
Joad 1984 at Louie logics 1984 question
for the podcast at Sims and left go
watching the Wednesday show Sims can you
do some shirt shopping for your boy left
go Wednesday better be laundry day just
wait till he watches this podcast whoo
what you wear yesterday is he talking
about the Wednesday so what wasn't here
so apparently he didn't look as cool as
I did hold on let's status quo pull it
up all right Wednesday oh he was wearing
the short sleeve blue but nap oh that he
didn't button on the top button because
woody said don't button it and he
listens to her like I said if woody said
wear a poop emoji hat I think he'd do it
alright moving on next one o'clock game
here the Green Bay Packers visiting the
Redskins in DC the Packers won oh and
one I hate that we have two teams that
tied I don't like saying one oh and why
I know tie 29:29 against Minnesota last
week the Redskins a 21-9 loss to the
Colts sitting at one and one spread in
this game Green Bay - three Sims we're
gonna come to you first on this one okay
Josh I would like to bet $100 on the
Green Bay Packers please you can have
that for thank you the first thing that
I am then just to my bottom baseline
point is this I expected Aaron Rodgers
to be better this week especially with
mobility things like that which is gonna
make them better in the red zone and
what I talked about with Tyrod Taylor
same thing with Alex Smith knew you were
gonna take the Packers when you said
this doesn't play to win
Alex Smith plays not to lose and field
goals aren't going to be there and
Rodgers in this bunch especially if
Aaron can move around a little bit
better uh the the Redskins are not a big
man to man defense and I think they'll
be very careful of doing that against
Green Bay I don't know if that's
necessarily a good formula against Aaron
Rodgers and company also the Redskins
defense is good but they haven't played
like juggernauts on the offensive side
of the ball yet I think the Redskins are
like the number one rated defense at
football I mean you play Arizona you're
gonna have great stat with the Rams
defense weren't great against you know I
mean Colts Colts like luck stats weren't
great but there was a big pass
interference calls and things like that
that affect that that doesn't get taken
to account but but yeah that would be my
over overriding factor there you know
how I feel about the Green Bay defense
the Green Bay defense could do a little
bit of everything and III think that the
Washington offense is solid and has some
weapons but I don't necessarily think
it's the most imaginative thing in the
world they don't make you defend the
downfield pass a whole lot and I think
between a guy like paedon and some of
the athletes they have in the back end
that it's just going to be too much I
don't think I think one of the strengths
of Washington like they're gonna be able
to stop the run and do things like that
but who the hell cares event screen
bankers are in trouble they're not
trying they're not gonna try this gonna
be shotgun let Rodgers do his thing yeah
I think this game is like close
throughout but I'm gonna pick the
Packers to win 27 to 21 all said done
for me I thought about you when I was
making this bet I just thought about
Alex Smith Chris Thompson Jordan Reed
that's the strength of this team they
operate in the middle Oren Burks is back
right athletic athletic linebacker for
the Green Bay Packers and they have a
lot of different safeties and stuff that
can play all over the field for a Jordan
Reed maybe we see Josh Jackson oh yeah I
think you could and I I don't see any I
don't think I think if Washington's
gonna win this game we're gonna need to
see a Paul Richardson deep ball against
some of the injured corners or the guys
that are coming in for Green Bay I just
don't trust that Alex Smith is going to
do that on the other side of the ball
Aaron Rodgers has had success against
the minovsky defense we saw in the
playoffs where they started slow and
then he came out firing in the second
half and if Aaron Rodgers on one leg can
do that to the Vikings defense I think
that he can also do that to the
Washington defense Washington when you
really look back start slow at home it
is a huge narrative right now
don't know finally being honest about
their attendant right it's very funny
that pictures don't work as we've seen
in other things in Washington that you
actually need numbers to have an impact
they had 20,000 empty seats yeah when
you look at it in September the last
five games at home for Washington
they're one in four in September so they
start slow in that Stadium right and
there's nothing that takes in a crowd
out more than an Aaron Rodgers Pat man
get the [ __ ] out of Maryland no
disrespect to Marilyn Josh I'm just
saying you're the Washington Redskins
play in Washington DC
take back your I mean back in the day
when I was growing up men was the
coolest place to go yeah and people your
Paula the people from the city just walk
to the stadium yeah and it was packed
and he could feel the stadium vibrate
when it comes to Dan Schneider it's
gonna go for the money right I am
putting my money mr. Bank please $100
also on the Green Bay Packers I just
think it's a really tough matchup for
Washington are you doing to be a total
west boy and go a hundred and all your
best is be going back to the old formula
I'm not gonna confirm or deny but I
might be making Green Bay aleph Cola
okay what are the odds this was my
question we didn't cover that left go
took a bath last yeah we've covered it
so many times you just don't show it to
podcast so we get to talk to you about
right right what are the odds he's a
better Jew than you he repented for my
sins yesterday III got on the podcast I
was like I'm sorry and I'm good oh and
four four left go lock them what are the
odds though that somebody like Alex
Smith takes a look in the mirror and
goes I'm gonna do it this week none I
mean it's like Bren what your is this he
plan he's had some games or he's taking
some shots
i I get it I just know I don't I know
I'm not putting my money I'm like in
Green Bay they're a lot yeah all right
next game here got a good one for you
Indianapolis the Colts at Philadelphia
the Colts coming off a really
interesting good 21 9 loss sorry win
last week against Washington
the Eagles coming off a 27 21 loss to
the Bucks both teams are 1 in 1 spread
in this game Eagles at home Eagles - 6
and a half left go we'll come to you
first I just want to look really quick
to see what the line started I got
it started at Eagles minus six so it's
sick really hasn't gone no actually it
started off at Eagles minus seven and
it's come down to six and a half and
most of the money right now in the Vegas
at this point is going on Indianapolis
this is a game that I went back a few
times I went to Carson Wentz's back this
is a completely new team the offensive
lines really good I don't want to get
too excited about what I saw it from the
Colts yeah but at the same point like
like here are two Vegas lines that are
very interesting the Eagles at home have
been incredible and their last ten at
home they're eight and two against the
spread I mean that's incredible against
the spread they are a different team at
home we saw them against Atlanta they're
different
the Colts their last eight games after
they've won a game what do you think
their record is in the next game gosh
one in seven oh and eight damn but that
was also Jacoby Brissette Colts night
right this that was also not Frank
Wright coach team right
I'm just curious we talked we're gonna
talk about Patricia later yeah does it
advantage more to Reich against his
former team or Peterson against Reich I
think more right because the matchups
gonna be just against Schwartz he's not
necessarily worried about that where
Peterson's more gonna talk about okay
yeah he might know things that Reich
likes to do on offense yes Peterson's
gonna be more concerned with I can never
say this guy's name the D chord never
floss what ever flow ever flus got you
I'm gonna get it for their ever flus so
he's really gonna go back I like the
name of an app he's got it he does he's
gotta go flus watch the last two weeks
he's gonna buy my toothpaste bad shark
tank Dallas Cowboys defense from last
year also he's gonna watch I went back
and forth of this a lot and there's
another quarterback today that I'm not
going to bet against this is one of them
I am gonna say that the Eagles win this
game but I'm putting $100 on the Colts
to cover the spread because Andrew Luck
is a quarterback that will take shots on
this defense and that's how you stay in
the game against the Eagles Matt Ryan
move the ball against the Eagles Ryan
Fitzpatrick move the ball against the
Eagles Andrew Luck is going to do it and
the Eagles are gonna have to push the
Colts on the running
and with a gibe Aang dub and Corey
Clement really not having the step that
I want him to right now and I know that
Carson Wentz is gonna be good I just
think it's too big of a spread for me
with a cold scene that might put up
points yeah I agree with a lot of a lot
of what you said I do think you know
even traditionally for Andrew Luck on
the road and I know you said the jacobi
per set thing they're usually not as
good in the road as they are at home you
know their offensive line is better this
year but on the road in a place in a
stadium where we know your team's gonna
be just pissed off from the way they
played last week let alone it's Carson
one starting it's gonna be electric
right it's gonna be electric you know
but at the same time yeah the man hasn't
played in a game in damn near like eight
months yeah I know so like you could be
excited I want Carson wants to be
incredible I shut up it's my turn to
talk
holy crap I mean he's gonna give me
another breakdown on his break down I
mean get look at blue steel and look at
yourself so then I guess the other thing
I look at - hey yes you're right about
the Andrew Luck thing with building to
take shots down the field against that
defense it's going to scare them to
degree you guys don't play as much
man-to-man as you used to so I don't I
think it can be a part of the game but
I'm not gonna say oh they're gonna win
the football game because of that
there's really again t-y Hilton and
they're still looking for that other guy
in the past game to be a dangerous
player like the tight ends are nice I'm
just talking about that dangerous guy
that you have to be scared of they don't
have that Ryan grant I guess yes right
who's who's a good like in in middle of
the field now he might is going to be
the guy we'll see what he does but I do
think that whence is going to bring
another element to the offense which is
I hop in the line throwing of the
football which you've been missing so
again I am going to bet $100 on the
Colts as well
Wow because I think six and a half is
too much okay and I think the Colts
often hey old man but I do think those
win this game I'm gonna go 20 for 20
that's that's exact and it could be 24
14
and they score a touchdown yeah that's
the Kings that that's and that's why
there are two quarterbacks that I'm not
betting against today and other one I'll
say later but yeah Andrew Luck is one of
those guys that he's a [ __ ] heart
attack when you bet against a guy and I
look at the Eagles and I think that
Carson Wentz is gonna be great but in
terms of the Colts and the Eagles
defense when until the Eagles answer
those questions like Fletcher Cox and
that d-line still played well and they
still let a big place yeah Darby can't
tackle Mills bites on double moves
there's a like McLeod and Jenkins
haven't been where they were last year
there's a lot of new guys at linebacker
like and the culture a team that in Week
one against the Bengals and in week two
against Washington their offense was
something it had an identity mm-hm and
pike coverage yeah plague coverage
Philadelphia and let your pass rush get
there alright guys I got a good one for
you coming up next here in the one
o'clock games Buffalo at Minnesota Bills
oh and two coming off a 31 20 loss to
the chargers Vikings 100 and one
Minnesota a 16 and a half point favorite
in this one 16 and a half point favorite
left guy will come to you first I'll
give you the betting lines on this one
against the spread in their last 25
games as home favorites the Vikings are
18 and 7 there are two teams that Vegas
has found to be reliable
the Patriots always and Mike Zimmer's
Vikings team Mike Zimmer what the
Vikings covers lines at at a rate that
can be compared to the Patriots and
Vegas hasn't been able to say that for a
very very long time
right the bills they're usually good
after consecutive losses but man this is
a very special Bills team and how bad
they are
with LeSean McCoy being banged up I went
back and forth a few times for one
reason I don't think the Vikings are a
team that puts teams out with this
offense I feel like they're very very
conservative and they're okay with being
up 14 I could see them up 17 to nothing
and then here comes the bills and Josh
Allen gets one throw and you're sitting
there going man Kirk Cousins got to dial
it up
I'm gonna tell you guys I haven't told
you yet for our fantasy team I'm
starting latavius Murray this week okay
the reason I expect the Vikings to get
ahead and then give the ball to latavius
not Dalvin cook that's my strategy so if
you guys didn't cook on the team we
always have a smirk I'm gonna go $100 on
Minnesota just because with I think that
LeSean McCoy is complaining about his
ribs and now he's playing a physical
team and Josh Allen hasn't had to play
on the road yet and it could be bad I'm
going $100 I'm innocent I thought he
liked he gave this whole build up like
he's gonna pick the bills and that Kirk
Cousins doesn't put teams away and then
he says the bills that was my concern
but then I went you know what I could
see this being the Josh Allen pick six
game where Minnesota scores for them and
they don't have to do I'm so
disappointed I was really hoping you'd
be stupid and pick Buffalo damn all
righty let's just make this quick
Buffalo's got no [ __ ] chance are you
kidding me yeah but sustained I don't
give a [ __ ] it's 16 and a half for a
reason it's gonna be 17 or 27 the bills
oh this is a left Cola I think so I mean
the funny thing is this is humans and
left go LOX before you go when you when
I take a favorite like this yeah I get
so much [ __ ] hate of course of course
dude I'm still mad that I didn't take
the Rams for a big money last week I
knew it the whole time and I just was
like oh I don't know
no Buffalo sucks I don't know what they
were thinking with blowing their
football team up the way they did the
quarter last year I mean they blew it up
even more this year and I don't
incognito retired and things like that
Eric wood right Eric wood retired Corti
Glen they trade them but there's just so
many things I look at on the road no
pass protection in a loud stadium shitty
offense Elias rush no no no receiver to
scare Minnesota in this slightest bit
and then you know hey Minnesota showed
me something last week Kirk Cousins
again he'll be aggressive and he's gonna
be he's gonna be able to bake a cake and
then left : have like a knish with it
later I mean he's gonna be able to do
with an issue like a knish I'm a big
fish guy I don't really
knishes they were always around giant
Stadium when I was growing up with jato
knishes I don't know no you know what I
watch the other day that I think we
should start doing again
I watched the clip of you trying Manila
pudding for the first time on the
podcast and it was really funny right I
want to start doing that again where you
try food thank you
but I'm thinking Vikings $200 or not the
Viking Viking I'm going Vikings 27 to 10
oh but that's barely a cover that's
barely a cover but I could see it being
37 to 10 if the game if it's in the
fourth quarter and the Vikings have a
14-point lead and the bills are driving
or the Vikings are driving we're a
hundred percent gonna get an Instagram
live of lefke watching that game come
down to the wire I want to see that
badly alright next game here guys on the
one o'clock slate you wanna do it one
more time
assemblé there's talk on the range let
me try let me try one hold on in
Holloway 3 2 I see Josh Alan I will
conquer him you will feel alright moving
on here the o and 2 Oakland Raiders was
eating this game is so interesting visit
to Miami Dolphins I'm excited for this
one because you guys did call out Miami
before the season and they're off to a
good start
the Dolphins three-point favorites in
this game it's Miami - 3 the dolphins
win this game I'm already halfway to my
bet that I put in they were five and a
half over/under no they were seven seven
yeah but I got him at plus 145 which
means I got great odds on him but three
is not halfway up so that's closer I had
I had this one for a long time the
Dolphins are the smart pick here I'm
just gonna say that first courting the
streaks in their last 12 games hosting a
West Coast team they're 11 and 1
straight up they just beat him right the
Raiders though in their last 10
September road games nine and one what
are you gonna do so I looked at the
teams right and I thought this I go
it's a Raiders team that just stopped
it's a Raiders team that's coming across
the country 1 o'clock against Miami it's
gonna be Hugh is it you've either man
you last week you were the great
I realize these games are gonna be
radiant muddy I realize every game on
today I was like bright sunshine I
looked at the weather and I realized
none of it said that I just made all
that last week I'm gonna check the
humidity for Sunday in Miami he told us
the hurricane was gonna ruin like I said
last week yeah anyway but then I went
the Raiders are desperate like really
desperate and I think when you look at
the Raiders game last week when you look
at the Raiders last two weeks they've
really come out the last two weeks and
punched people in the mountains they
were beating the Rams in the game one
and week two they were the better team
against the Broncos for three and a half
quarters oh man the what what 75 percent
humidity in Miami it's supposed to be
muggy as hell a.m. under storms too so
it's gonna be moist in the air and
curtains gonna have pet stains I've
gotta had super freaking gross of all
the quarterbacks though that are really
good on the road as an under like as an
underdog Derek Carr is up there I could
see that he really does ruin a lot of
games I combined two things in my head I
combined the fact that you said to me
about the jet skiing that the Jets
really dominated that game and that the
one weakness that we haven't gotten to
seem to be tested the Dolphins is a team
that punches in the mouth and runs right
and that's how the Raiders have gotten
up on the Rams and they've gotten up on
the Broncos the middle core of the
Raiders remains the same Oh simile
Hudson and Jackson yeah and they are
gonna come in and they're gonna push I
am going with a surprise here I'm going
Raiders plus three and I'm putting a
hundred I think that Derek Carr a team
that's super against the ropes Miami
might be feeling themselves right now
and you know what it's gonna be humid
but if you're the team it's humid for
both teams yeah and if you're the team
getting punched in the mouth and then
Ryan Tannehill who we know wants to be
conservative has to convert third downs
I think that the Raiders go in there and
pull off an upset and win this game
John Gruden's first win of the year do
you agree Sam okay so I am going to put
ten dollars on the Miami Dolphins okay
but I don't feel good about this Allah
that's why I'm going $10 okay there's
too many things that concern me here
first of all I picked the Dolphins to
win the game 23 to 20 and this game I
don't know push I don't know yeah and I
don't know if I feel necessarily
confident about it
things scare me like this the Raiders
offensive lines been better than I think
people realize even now even on the edge
the tackles have played pretty good they
only lit up one sack last week against
Denver so it's Denver right that's what
I mean
so it they're protecting so I value that
pass rush in Miami so well but I don't
think it's gonna hit home as much as
they'd like you talked about we've
talked about how yes I do think the
Miami lacks big people not only in the
middle of the defense but also their
linebackers aren't big either and so
that concerns me and I know Gruden will
stay patient on the run and you
mentioned to the offensive line of the
Raiders and all those things is very
impressive to out of the fact that ya
Gruden's ass is he's hot right now
yes he's mad they're extremely desperate
they are Owen too and um you know I
guess what am I trying to say here I
wanted to flip around the other side oh
that's the other side I want to talk
about Miami's offense you guys found it
very uncreative very uncreative in week
one I again don't think the Raiders have
a pass rush to disrupt things but I've
liked the Raiders game plans on defense
for the most part they were just out man
to that man's game and got a little worn
down there so that's why I just don't
know where this game goes like I said
I'm picking Dolph is 23 to 20 yeah but I
don't feel great about it's why I'm only
doing just add a little bit of stuff the
Raiders have played 16 games in East
three you know
one so this teams beaten the Dolphins
this rosters beat my masters and I
remember what they did to the Bucs two
years ago since his rookie year 2014
Derek Carr has covered more games as a
road underdog than any other quarterback
in the NFL he's 16 and 11 against the
spread so you know Derek Carr is good at
being an underdog yeah and I thought he
looked good last week and he's just
getting more and more confident but I
think this is gonna be a Marshawn Lynch
bust them in the mouth yeah I could
certainly see that
all right guys next game at one o'clock
here we're going to Denver at Baltimore
Broncos coming off a close win over the
Raiders last week 20 to 19 there - and
OH Ravens coming off a Thursday Night
Football loss to the Bengals 3423
Baltimore is 1 and 1 on the season in
this game the spread Ravens - 5 and a
half
Sims we're gonna come to you first on
this one ok um a lot of things here
Baltimore had the extra time off right
yeah playing in Baltimore is a tough
place to play it is it's one of the
loudest outdoor stadiums in the sport
and I look at Denver and hey Denver's
won two football games but it hasn't
been cleaned yet I mean it really has it
I could say they were a little fortunate
in both games
I do like Case Keenum and the things
he's done his aggressive mindset all of
that I do worry about their offensive
line and company being overpowered in
this game their offensive line has been
good at the same point I thought about
this right who they played yes Natalie
nope I know two teams that came grab is
going and I don't know if I can't answer
the question yet it's better than what I
saw last year oh no you can't too late
too late I have ruled that live changes
are allowed they're allowed yeah okay I
want that to be a thing for the seats
okay so either way I'll do it I think
also you know denver denver denver spaz
rush everything they do there man I just
would have a hard time thinking they
overpowered the Ravens offense a line on
a consistent basis out of do the fact
that hey Denver's secondary it's good it
doesn't blow me away I do think if we
see the Joe Flacco we saw a weak one and
in the preseason yeah
that it couldn't be a different story
here I'm picking Denver to cover the
spread
okay I'm going to go $100 on the Denver
Broncos just because I don't have a I
don't have enough faith in the Ravens
offense yet to say they can win a game
by more than five and a half points I
literally everything that Sims just said
is a hundred percent might take
everything about this matchup makes you
want to go the Ravens are gonna beat
them and I think the Ravens are going to
beat the Broncos and the Ravens 22:17 is
when I picked the score makes sense to
me couldn't that be 20 to 40 Norse it
like totally makes sense Broncos in the
last 10 Ron games are one a nine like
they're not a good road team at all
everything about it I completely agree
with what you're saying
the Ravens though when they're favored
by five or more they rarely cover it's
been a total of 18 times they've been
favored by five or more since 2014 and
against the spread they've only covered
it six times right I have I went Denver
$100 as well because I think it was that
the change or not the gel I had Denver
originally okay we couldn't change it
because I think that this is gonna be a
game where the Ravens are controlling
the entire game the one thing that I I
think I look at this Ravens team to not
have CJ Moseley mmm is such an enormous
thing I feel like that defense has run
around the middle linebacker they're
missing Jimmy Smith yeah and CJ Mosley
and I look at this team and I think
Emmanuel Sanders goes off because when I
saw from the Bengals against the Ravens
and this is what you texted us the
Bengals had better athletes on the edge
the Bengals are missing Joe Mixon on the
offense so they're gonna have Giovanni
Bernard as their main run I'm talking
about the wrong [ __ ] game excuse me
scuse me scuse me scuse me sorry that
was I can I confused Bengals you're
talking about Phillip Lindsey on the
edge of the defense of the Braves he
outrunning us like the run the
linebackers of the Ravens I could
totally see Emanuel Sanders Courtland
Sutton
if Demaryius right Thomas could catch a
ball I think that they have an
for the weapons and more importantly
they have a quarterback that's gonna
throw them all right they can be
aggressive they can be a dress they can
close the lead in a hurry and and so if
Denver connects on Emmanuel Sanders
cross her and he takes it and then I'm
relying on Joe Flacco I got very upset
about Joe Flacco last yeah I would I did
do because even the yards and some of
the throws unit they were like just
throw it up and their guys made a great
catches it was pitiful I was impressed
with John Brown I was not impressed with
Joe Flacco his inability to get away
from the rush he was still looking slow
the bengals pass rush is very good von
miller should be able to get in there a
little bit too I just don't have
confidence that if Denver's scores a
little bit
Baltimore's rip they're there I was I
had higher hopes for them this season
and I don't have it yet I I just don't
think the Ravens can cover that if it
was three definitely the rate am I wish
I would have switched would have been
fun wonder if he would have switched if
I took Baltimore do you think copied you
yeah no because you had the same fears
yes and and that's my fear
all right guys next game here Cincinnati
at Carolina yeah in this game the
Panthers a three very favorite Panthers
minus three and let go let's start with
you on this one
okay when you take a look at the the
spread here the Panthers are one of
those teams that has a decided advantage
early in the year at home their last six
games at home there's six and OH
straight up they will have you what do
you think of it the atmosphere at
Carolina you know I don't think it's
anything special pretty weak it is it is
pretty weak I never found it to be a
huge home-field advantage playing there
okay this is me listening to Simms of me
taking your information and using it
against ya the one thing that you said
about the Atlanta game is Carolina's
focused on stopping the run right now I
get to get in my Joe Mixon play no Joe
Mixon for Cincinnati right no starting
Center Billy price for Cincinnati the
middle of that offense if they're gonna
be able to shut down the run yeah and
then sit back in zone and do and kind of
sit back I expect AJ Green have a big
play yeah but when Carolina eliminates
one part of their of the other team's
offense yeah that's a lot better
right Cincinnati still doesn't have
vantes perfect since Annie's can still
get a pass rush but I think Carolina
kind of wants to you know dump off and
and I think that it's another big game
for for McCaffrey against a linebacking
core that's kind of all over the place
yeah I like Carolina at home here and I
think Cincinnati might be feeling
themself a little bit Carolina you know
at home after a loss I'm taking Carolina
$100 here on the Panthers okay there's a
tough one here it's a super tough I find
them very evenly matched really tough
one I'm not gonna get super high on Andy
Dalton after one game against a foe that
he plays a lot and he knows that deep
yeah I trust I trust Cam Newton over
totally understand that I do think the
bangles are the more talented football
team the biggest thing that scares me is
Andy Dalton bursts Cam Newton it does
but I can't be a hater forever either
and I got a respect that bill lasers
given this offense some creative things
as the floor it's been two weeks in a
row and you're right it's a familiar
opponent last week but but still I've
been impressed with the overall look but
even the preseason I was like what are
they what are they trying to accomplish
I think when I break it down at the
simplest form I worry about Carolina's
offensive line I really do it's still a
very good defensive line by the
Cincinnati Bengals and my biggest
concern is damn did they got some cover
people and Carolina I just don't know if
anybody can separate from that that's
the thing so that scares me shut up so
then okay then you flip it over to the
other side and yet that Mixon thing
bothers me it does and so does the Billy
price thing I'm guess I'm what I'm
really thinking is I think bill lazer
will have some gadget type runs to move
the ball that way and I've been pretty
impressed with Andy Dalton to this part
I'm not gonna I don't feel totally great
about this but Josh I'm going to bet
$100 on the Cincinnati Bengals I love it
that's a good and I think that
Cincinnati is going to win this football
game
22:16 hmm I mean it's tough it's tough
for me to pick against Cam Newton in
Carolina I think when you talk about
what it's like playing there I think
but it is Superman's there and Superman
don't ever give up he's always in a game
he's always gonna hang in the pocket yes
he plays a win he's not afraid to throw
a laser down the field when they're down
by 10 points and it might be a bad thing
at times he throws interception but he
plays to win
and that's my other thing was I think
the NFC is better than the AFC yeah and
this kind of goes out with these two
teams the Bengals are two five and one
straight up against the NFC since 2016
flip side when the Panthers play the AFC
their last 13 games ten and three right
they just beat up on the AFC all right
guys next game on the one o'clock slate
here we are going to Houston the on2
texans coming off a loss to the Titans
hosting the oh and two Giants coming off
a loss to the Cowboys on Sunday Night
Football two desperate teams here left
go we're gonna start with you I hate
this game
I think that both I don't trust either
tears 10-6 as the spread by the way
sorry man um and that's I'm just gonna
make that point I'm going with the
Giants hundred dollars plus six because
neither of these teams should be favored
by more than three points over any other
team I think that it's move from three
to six because of how publicly Eli was
embarrassed and how public the first two
games have been right but I look at this
game and I go until I see deshaun Watson
not hesitate until I see him start
running I don't know if I can really
invest in this team it's not bad the old
line is I will say this it's their first
home game and I get it
him at home could be completely
different but I like Shermer as more of
a coach than Billy O'Brien I know that
JJ Watt against Erick flowers maybe the
biggest mitts match in the entire NFL
this week but if Odell goes off for a
touchdown just like we saw Tennessee got
a punt touched like a punt fake
touchdown last week do I have that much
faith that Houston's can be able to
march down the field against the Giants
I will say I love will fuller in this
matchup will fuller with DeSean Watson's
always great and with the injury to Eli
Apple I could really see the Giants kind
of letting him open but I just don't
trust the Texans that much I'm gonna go
$100 in the gym yeah I think there's a
lot
not trust in the matchup yet the Giants
I mean I could see this being ugly
offensive performance once again I mean
certainly I mean it's that is what we
said before the Year seven weeks in a
row it could be off I mean yeah the
Texans defensive front it's it's real
and I think it's only gonna get better
as the season goes on because it's JJ
Watt getting more healthy Jadeveon
Clowney
out there right the Whitney Merciless is
the world they're gonna get better as
well you know
hey DJ readers one of the best details
in football I do worry about the
secondary in Houston a little bit verse
these weapons that that the New York
Giants have this is not the fastest
defensive football in Houston where I do
think I could at the sacrum Barclays
gets in some matchups one-on-one against
these linebackers could be a little
scary but yeah it's hard for me to have
faith in the Giants and some things and
then Houston you're right - hey Houston
Houston Houston Houston stop putting in
three tight ends and trying to be like
it's 2002 is over okay it's deshaun
Watson your quarterback Bruce Ellington
fuller and DeAndre Hopkins need to be on
the field every play of the game
make the field spread it out let the
Sean bond against this deep right you're
not gonna beat them in a phone booth and
that's why I'm in the Giants I'm hoping
they try and sell fumble yeah I gotta
think they he's had to see their success
Houston last week as compared to when
they had the three receivers 11
personnel on the field as compared to
when they did the other now yeah deshaun
Watson you made the point it is scary um
I'm picking Houston to win this game I'm
gonna pick you soon to win 21 to 17 so
that's why Josh I will be putting $100
on the New York Giants that will
definitely not be a left go along now
too many too many things to worry about
that that game Saints Falcons I have no
idea like there's a number of these
games that like I just would never touch
if you like we were just talking
Cincinnati Carolina who the hell knows I
don't know it's it those are there's a
lot of coin flip games in this and this
is a weird week it's just all so this is
the fact the NFL we talk about it every
year the difference between the best
team in the league and the worst team in
the league is not that much it's not
exactly right I don't know
oh yeah Buffalo and carrot I mean Aries
are stuck all right guys next game
moving on here Tennessee at Jacksonville
we just talked about the Titans before
their one line coming off the win over
Houston Jacksonville led by the 38th
best quarterback in the league Blake
bortles and we're in there to a know
after beating the Patriots last week
Jacksonville a six and a half point
favorite at home against the Titans Sims
will come to you first okay hey
Jacksonville is awesome Jacksonville is
awesome we know that Jacksonville is
coming off one of the biggest wins of
their franchise history and at least in
resources are high they are emotions are
high and of course they're a good
football team
Tennessee matches up well with the
Jacksonville jacket what way well
Tennessee has the kind of cover guys on
the outside that can go okay we're not a
like gonna be totally threatened to play
you man-to-man if we have to stop the
power running game even with the way
Malcom Butler is allowing huge plays
this you know what but again he's been
on the people every time like he's there
it's not like it's like toast
it's like Kyle fuller for Chicago so
keeps letting up touchdowns but he's
like in there right I mean he's gonna
let up they're gonna let up plays when
you have to play man-to-man you know 40
snaps a game against like cheetahs like
hey we want you to cover the cheat all
over the field and never let them catch
a ball okay you try that coach tell me
how that works out that's like but but I
do think they're gonna be creative
enough to to do some different things in
their coverage I do think you know I'm
them in them in their defense they can
play a big boy football a little bit I
don't think they can get steamrolled by
this Jacksonville run game and run
attack Tennessee has a formula and has
Jacksonville's number to a degree okay
and Blaine Gabbert I look at him and go
man he's gonna want to go back to
Jacksonville and kind of crap on them a
little bit because his career didn't
start all that great I do think that you
know our offensive coordinator there
Matt Lafleur he can have enough of a
quick passing game and things that he's
gonna steal from a Kyle Shanahan from
Kyle's last year's performance against
his Jacksonville defense - we're not
that I am expecting a big performance
but they can move the ball and stay
respectable so Bob
line here is I'm taking Tennessee for
$100 six and a half points is just a
little too much for me I'm picking
Jacksonville to win the game 16 to 13
but I I don't know there's just
something about me to says I don't think
they're gonna win by a touchdown I a
hundred percent when this is a possible
deflate game yeah but I can only imagine
how much Jacksonville has been talking
to each other about the fact that
Tennessee swept them last year they've
heard it all offseason Tennessee 3 and 1
against the Jaguars in the last four
Jaguars are 10 and OH in their last 10
games in the early afternoon they're
playing at 1 o'clock they're 10 and oh
right straight up right I think that
this is the year that the Jaguars put it
all together I think that this is a
Jaguars team that's gonna come out for
blood
and I know that Tennessee's had their
number and that's actually why I think
it benefits Jacksonville it's a new
coaching staff than the last few years
that's had their number
this is Vrabel Rabil wants to come at
you and bash your right in the face all
the time I'm going $100 on Jacksonville
that's pretty good thanks do that again
without I pretty good what kind of cats
purr do you know big cats feline cats
what does that mean like lions don't
purr like mountain lions do ya like a
panther and things like that they they
they're in the feline cat category yes
thank you I look at this team and I look
at the Tennessee Titans and their best
plays have been with they're shifty fast
guys that Dion Lewis has the t1 tailors
they're not running away from
Jacksonville Blake bortles at home is
different than Blake bortles on the road
and is well-documented I think that this
Tennessee team while I love their cover
corners they've been getting beat a
little bit and Jacksonville's been
really good at taking advantage of the
one-on-one matchups as athletic as I
think a Dori Jackson and Malcom Butler
and Logan Ryan are I just think the wide
receivers for the Jaguars are more
athletic than they are right
I think the Jaguars come out there
wanting to put this AFC South nonsense
to rest and I think they go out there
and I think they actually beat the
Titans by 10 I like the Jaguars here in
a big way
okay all right guys last game on the one
o'clock slate here San Francisco 49ers
one in one coming could be like 50 to 40
coming off a close win against the Lions
last week 30 to 27
Kansas City first home game of the
season their two-and-oh after a 40 to 42
to 37 win against the Steelers Kansas
City a six and a half point favorite in
this game left go will come to you first
I went back and forth in this a million
times but it came down to one simple
point I am I'm not betting against
mahomes anymore $100 on the Kansas City
Chiefs do I think the Niners can make it
a shootout sure which defense do I think
could actually stop the other team I
actually have more faith in the Niners
defense Rueben Foster's back oh here
they go but in the end I'm just not
betting against the Chiefs I know that
the Chiefs sometimes get overinflated in
Arrowhead but I'm not betting against
the Chiefs until it happens so I'm going
with the Chiefs yeah okay breakdown it's
it's a scary one
I would like to place $200 oh my god
on the San Francisco four years is gonna
win this game outright win this game 34
31 games everyone what's the chocolates
home game real is a great big fight
which is I could totally see it all the
hype right now I mean sometimes first of
all there's more pressure playing at
home than there is on the road road you
can unite it's us versus the world at
home it's damn we're supposed to win and
our crowds behind us and there's all the
emotions of that I want to please my
crowd and all of those things this is
what scares me more than anything your
shootout point I'm with you that I do
think this is I'm picking the 49ers to
win 34 to 31 this is what really scares
me though more than anything for Kansas
City I do think the Niners defense is a
little better than people realize or at
least then I even gave it credit for
hopefully Jack whiskey plays yep that
would be nice and Reuben Foster being
back is certainly a positive team you
know I like my guy in the middle -
what's his name the other guy like
Warner Warner yeah 48 but I think the
biggest thing that I look at is the
running the ball of the San Francisco
49ers there's a reason they're the
number one team in the NFL and rushing
it's probably because they play the
Detroit Lions well it's certainly part
and the average weight of their
linebackers are 212 dirt they're third
in the league right I get that
also I worry about that yes but like the
did Kansas City become the Steel Curtain
of rust out running this running so
they're gonna get running or stopping
the run I wanted to say Mott so that's
what I worry about shut up shut up
you've already talked like you have a
[ __ ] problem you have a beef well as
that I know mark you many smart people
start to correct it at some point
holy crap so yeah so I do I look at
their ability to run the football and
control the clock and keep them off the
field to a degree where it could hurt
the Kansas City Chiefs yeah pull it away
from them
stop [ __ ] asking me first um well why
you you because we've established after
week one that you should go first
because otherwise I Oreos I've been
rotating it it won't matter which way it
goes you oreo either way all right good
it does not matter so I guess that
that's what concerns me is their ability
to control the clock control the line of
scrimmage in the run game Kansas City's
defense it's the worst in football it's
the worst they suck so I worry about
that and you know that that like even
against the Minnesota Vikings 49ers had
a few runs that were okay wasn't
horrible
I think this offensive line for the
49ers is pretty damn good when it comes
to the run game the big question is
really Jimmy Garoppolo right yes Jimmy
Garoppolo missed some throws again last
week to put the Lions away and put them
away for good
but I'm just taking a hunch here and a
49er team that I don't think played its
best game yet they've kind of messed up
some situations and another team that is
men we're awesome and we got this
awesome quarterback and I'm just gonna
pick my man Kyle Shanahan to steal the
game 34 31 Kyle Shanahan on the road as
an underdog yeah is five and two against
the spread so he let me think about it
the Washington game I did it with a crap
what was the kid's name again
Iowa Oh Beathard see he did it with
Beathard last year he was covering the
spring my big thing that was my thing is
I think Jimmy's gonna miss Kittel across
the middle one time okay it's it's not
the same issue as he did last week right
that was the same thing and he had a
number of throws that he made and then I
can't get over my head that pick six
that got called back huh I know throwing
an out route with the game on the line
to her running back and not even looking
at him you're the Chiefs they're bad but
they can make some plays - yeah and it
just you're right the running game
they're gonna have to get up early and
really just pound the rock but that's
what scares me it's just six and a half
points - I just can't against a really
good offense like yeah just that's a
little much for me alright guys moving
into the four o'clock games here first
up the battle for Los Angeles the
Chargers visiting the Rams I was
surprised by this line
so are a seven-point favorite in this
one we both second Chargers here Sims
will go to you first I am taking
Chargers hundred dollars hundred dollars
alright so we're both on this yes hi I
know that the Rams Taj Olson beaver he
go Apple Chargers la la charges iPhone
uh I get that the Rams are really good
one that segment you did not I didn't
get to give two hats away than when my
to be and we'll pick the girl didn't
come hash tag rigged um I know that the
Rams have it all I said Sims first on
this one okay but I think what it's okay
go ahead it just doesn't matter
I love Phillip Rivers as an underdog in
a seven point game
let him go baby spread out that Rams
defense that wants you to pound that
right up the middle who are the Rams
played the Rams have played the Raiders
who are trying to run right in their
face and Steve Wilkes team Mike McCoy's
offense that for some reason what David
Johnson is publicly admitting we run up
the middle too much the Chargers are the
number one team they play 98 percent 11
personnel think about that yeah that 11
personnel one running back one tight end
three wide receivers on the field all
the time I know they have Marcus Peters
I know they have a keep to leave but
they're gonna spread them out it's a
shootout and it's an away game right
okay they're in this they're sleeping in
their beds tonight and I think they're
the team that feels like they're cheated
in this whole thing there's one approve
you oh man right there are definitely
fun to go Superbowl Chargers are
forgotten about Chargers are like oh
when are they gonna collapse this
respected Phillip Rivers let me get it
chased I I just have a hard time
thinking the Rams are gonna win by more
than that the Rams are the true picking
the Rams no I I'm picking this way we
have to win the football which I am let
me see what I picked there I picked the
Rams to win a very close one 27:24 this
might have to be a left go lock so it's
just yes
the Chargers offense it's got some
special attributes about it right I mean
I think that's the the thing that needs
to be said more than anything and the
rams just have too many weapons all over
the field on both sides of the ball for
me not to pick them to win the
game but by what is it seven buy more
than 7.7 I just I can't I can't fly with
that against this Chargers defense it's
just look at the Chargers and I go what
team in the NFL is seven points better
than them I don't see it yeah I know I'm
with you I know that Bose is out and I
know that if the Rams would go with Todd
Gurley and they're just pound in the
rock I just think that Philips gonna and
the the r8 the Chargers like to play
from behind ya know I think the Chargers
are gonna probably be behind and then
Rivers is gonna throw a pick late to
seal the deal all right guys moving on
the Cowboys visiting the Seattle
Seahawks this week wildly interesting
Seattle oh and two after the loss on
Monday Night Football Dallas 1 & 1 after
beating the Giants last week in this
game at home the Seahawks a 1 and a half
point favorite Sims we'll start with you
wait really quick on the last game
because I didn't get to get this in
there in there our last 10 games as a
road underdog in six and a half or more
the Chargers against the spread have
covered eight of them Wow
so when they're there big-time underdogs
Philip Rivers is there going we're not
gonna lose by that much but are they on
the road or are they home I don't know
the last one that made me think was
remember the Patriots game they were
like seven point underdogs I think
should have won that game they should he
loved that did they cover that spread
they did I thought maybe they lost by
like one point there and they lost by
six it was a six if I remember right
okay so Dallas Seattle okay
in and out I didn't Seattle excuse me a
course is gonna be a place that's revved
up ready to go hey first thing is
Seattle's offense first to Dallas the
events negative ghostrider the pattern
is full okay this do you want that mean
this they're playing the three best
defensive lines maybe in the sport three
weeks in a row the Seattle Seahawks and
having to play you know Denver Chicago
and now oh what do you do you get a week
off with the Dallas Cowboys yeah watch
out Dallas is d-line is real its
ferocious it can do everything
middle linebacker plays good and the
number one improvement for their
football team is their secondary Chris
Rashard being there from Seattle ie but
he doesn't have it enough necessarily in
knowledge of this offense right because
it's a different offense with
Schottenheimer there but regardless I
just like everything he's done on the
defensive side of the ball so far and
they
have some cover people like Byron Jones
and shinobi illuzzi on the out edge on
the edge they can live on island they
can play zone they can do it all that's
where I like them now to flip it to the
other side man
Dallas's offense it sucks I mean it
sucks all they threw a big pass on the
first play and then they [ __ ]
disappeared for the rest of the game but
I don't have a whole lot of faith in
Seattle's defense and I do think this is
a game that you weren't impressed at all
about their performance against Chicago
no not really no really no I think if
true Brisky hits two or three throws
here and there the game was gonna be
over and they're gonna get blown out
that's what scares what's the difference
being too risky and AK yeah I don't know
doc I don't risk a better offense yes
four Biscay is better weapon right trust
it but but I do worry about Seattle's
defense against this run game I think
they're gonna be able to run the ball on
Seattle a little bit just to control the
clock I think this game is gonna be very
close I am going with the Dallas Cowboys
for $80 80 and I am picking the Dallas
Cowboys to win this game though 17 to 16
up in Seattle but this is yeah I'm is a
coin flip game since 2009 the Seahawks
are nine and OH in home openers they are
13 and OH straight up in September at
home their last 13 home games I know I
look at this and it's gonna be like 12
to 10 yeah something like that right I
envision this happening this is the
moment that I pictured in my head
we're traveling back to the future
Michael Dixon yes
pins Dallas inside the five like four
times in a row right and that Dallas
offense is operating in the shadow of
their own goalpost for a lot of the game
Seattle is going to score a
non-traditional way a Tyler Lockett punt
return a blocked punt a interception
return for a touchdown
Russell Wilson somehow scores a
touchdown to me it comes down to is Zeke
going to pop one yeah I am going with
Seattle at home I'm going $100 on
Seattle
I think that Russell Wilson is going to
be running for his life for most of this
game yeah I just I just like Seattle at
home there are certain things I like in
Seattle home in September's one of those
games no I think the Seahawk with a
cowboy come up there with a gun and that
Seahawk Potts legal he's been smoking a
little I just think it's scary might be
in the right flying pattern yeah yeah
sorry I didn't get any cowboy uh you
didn't bet enough 100 yeah it has to be
over a hundred eighty bucks and expect
to get sound effects I didn't know that
yeah Nikki genie is money man okay yeah
all right I better get double play when
they go 200 he did okay when ding-dings
yeah yeah I did not notice these little
things welcome welcome to the show Sims
alright last game in the afternoon Slade
here Chicago visiting Arizona the Bears
a six point favorite on the road against
the Cardinals I want to do one nugget
before you go and leave it just go ahead
little F go sprinkle our Oreo me okay
and their last 17 games on the road
earth what do you think the Bears record
is Oh can't be good
17 games last 17 games last year it was
bad and then they had the number to pick
the year before that so I mean it's got
to be like 2 and 15 yeah thanks thanks
man I had this as an Arizona cover I was
like they're gonna do it they're finally
gonna do it and then I've realized I've
bet with Arizona the first two we not
Washington I [ __ ] that I'm going Chicago
minus 6 do I have faith in my childre
whiskey on the road might kill Travis I
really don't like I really don't yeah
but do I think that this offense of
Arizona should have success against this
bears defense after what I've seen from
the Bears I know what's at home and I
know the Bears have a huge home-field
advantage but I'm going Chicago $100
just because it's out Arizona just think
I know it's at Arizona and that's where
my fear is like I wanna take Arizona to
cover at home Arizona sometimes plays
better at home and Chicago stinks on the
road like what have I seen for a glimmer
to feel confident in Arizona I just
don't you know in Chicago yeah I mean
the Arizona offense I just think when
you look at that side of the ball
there's nothing for me to feel good
about right
now Steve Wilk says he wants to get Dave
Johnson on the edge but well I'll see it
when I believe yeah great I mean good
that's you know everybody's got a game
plan that's like you got punched in the
face as Mike Tyson once said so the the
that is that's what do you see you
always used to say okay keep planes are
good until somebody gets punched in the
face that's how he talks but the I so I
have no faith in the Arizona offense I
really don't I mean none absolutely none
run game who the hell's there to be
worried about in the past game I think
this bears defense is special then I
flip it over to the other side yes mr.
Cobb risky is not lighting the world on
fire but this Arizona defense is
certainly nothing to write home about
either and I do think Mitchell cheb
risky is going to continue to get better
nor was he as bad as everybody is trying
to say he was and hopefully his coach
can maybe start to instill some calmness
I feel like his coach was kind of
backtracking after the game the other
night to finally like okay actually he's
my quarterback and I need to start
saying something good about him because
I'm coming off as a jerk-off how I'm
trying to like send out these hidden
messages how I don't like them so I
think the Bears offenses will be too
much handle too much to handle for the
Arizona defense as well oh throughout
the all over the field the Bears have
weapons they can run the football they
can protect the passer if they want
there'll be more in the offense because
I know true Biscay is still learning and
that's the thing so I am going to
hundred dollars on these Chicago Bears
little bit wiser Cardinal Oh give me two
Cardinals nuts to bring them over they
don't leave the nuts and then I'll eat
you too
so I just have no faith in Arizona it's
a six-point spread and I just don't
sorry you just went right into battle oh
man my question is this yeah Chandler
Jones Patrick Peterson yeah Steve Wilkes
his defensive guy are they not good are
they are they are they that are they
just not that talented it ever their
position dejan Buchanan's tougher
they're getting overpowered right now
yeah they can get a little bit of
everything and I still think that there
they're trying to adjust to a scheme
that they haven't played and you know
there was a three for Pittsburgh schemes
and now they're trying to play for three
Carolina football and I mean they've
been outscored like fifty four to six
yes and they're a mainly zone defense
and even with Patrick Peterson they're
not trying to play a ton of man-to-man
any Israel and the thing that I so kills
the Cardinals is who's the deep threat
like Larry Larry Fitzgerald's great and
Cristian Kirk is great he's a slot guy
but he's a slot guy there's no one that
makes you go deep so it kind of negates
David Johnson that's you know like
that's why I just that's why I'm I'm
pickin bears the 124 ten I just don't
see how the Cardinals can muster up
drives with a nominated for Biscay pick
something like that yes but but to me
it's like I thought that line I thought
it was gonna be like Chicago minus nine
right I thought they were gonna go super
high just because the public I know that
Chicago's let lead slip but like two
weeks in a row they're up like two
scores in the third or fourth quarter
and I just don't see Arizona do anything
on this defense think about who's come
back on Chicago you're better in hager
exactly I'm convincing myself to a left
go locks but who's come back against
Chicago Aaron Rodgers and Russel Wilson
I don't care if Josh Rosen comes in or
Sam Bradford they don't got the guy they
don't got the weapons it's too simple
for a guy like Vic Fangio he's gonna be
all over that might be my third or
fourth left go long go go alright
gentlemen moving us is but it's also the
one that when they Arizona wins I feel
like a news well if they win hey it's
nothing you could do they're not the
better football team and they don't have
the better players and they don't have
the better coaches so different when I
look into the aspects I go strike three
you're out
Sunday Night Football the New England
Patriots headed out on the road to
Detroit to take on the Lions the
Patriots are a seven point favorite in
this game Sims you are snapping your
fingers why I am snapping them because
they're going to Detroit okay I don't
know what I'm talking about okay
uh I mean Detroit's knocked a good
football team e there okay and I'm not
impressed at all by their second-half
surge against the Niners not necessarily
I think it's a lot of Matt Stafford okay
and
it's a I thought Stafford was terrible
they hunt return touchdowns I got called
back they had a pick six touched yes I
know yeah I get all that and Matt
Stafford is still dangerous and I'm
betting $100 on New England so let's
just start like that okay I packed my
car in the Detroit yadd and Tommy's here
and I like McDaniels over Patricia
McDaniels greater than Patricia all
right so that's where I just look at
this more than anything I think New
England is clearly the better football
team I do worry about hey Stafford not a
great pass rush from New England New
England playing man-to-man Stafford can
make some big plays in the throw game we
know that the pass game as they say but
at the end of the day I just don't see
how it happens and I think matching wits
bill knowing what Matt likes to do and
then Josh knowing what Matt likes to do
yeah and I'm just gonna take Josh and
Bill in that matchup in general and I'm
gonna pick the past to win the game 31
to 20 but I get very scared that it
could be 31 to 20 with two minutes left
and Matt Stafford scores a touchdown as
3127 that's why I didn't go hard I
almost talked about making this a
200-dollar game but that that aspect is
the only thing to help me back my fear
I'm going $100 on the Patriots as well
here is a Boston accent uh pack the car
have it yeah I'm focused on important
things like betting this isn't growing a
double-digit loss the Patriots against
the spread yeah against the spread our
undefeated 21 and six like their numbers
in Vegas are in seen and seen in seen
when they're favored by seven and more
they're six and one against the spread
they're incredible in night games as
well eight and two on Sunday Night
Football and Stafford and the Lions are
actually really bad in primetime yeah
that's funny
my fear is when I'm listening to
Lombardi and I'm thinking about how you
beat the Patriots yeah and you said you
spread them out but I don't trust the
Lions to be smart yeah exactly I have a
feeling they're gonna be like let's put
in LeGarrette Blount idiot yeah they're
not greater than the creative enough to
be let's spread it out they need to have
those three receivers on the field with
Theo Riddick and just doin crossers and
screams but I don't trust them
I trust McDaniels and Belichick and
after a loss to the to the to the
Jaguars like that in primetime I will
never get bet against the Patriots I'm
with you this is another team that I'm
thinking being my left Kolok just
because when you can side with the
Patriots after a loss that's a team that
I want about my money more be in my
radar my other thing is this is yeah we
could talk about Stafford and not
getting a lot of pass rush but the Lions
aren't gonna get a big pass rush against
the Patriots and the Patriots against
that defense Darius Slade might not play
like night night
the Patriots might put up 42 night night
yeah this is oh this is a left Quahog
yeah
all right gentlemen last game of the
week Monday Night Football the
Pittsburgh Steelers oh one in one he's
doing spreadsheets over there and doing
a show yeah I was thinking about this we
need to get Josh a keyboard that doesn't
sound like he's reprogramming NASA this
is how you talk here just type a normal
word type in josh pendrick holy crap
like that
alright last like a little cardinal
woodpecker Pittsburgh on just broke his
computer by typing Pittsburgh on the
road oh one and one facing the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers to a no the Steelers one
point favorites on the road in this one
all right I'm gonna go take it away
desperation Mike Tomlin is being called
out by every major prognosticator
bloviator and talk--i tater in the world
like that was good rhyming Steven a
Smith Max Kellerman Chris Simms
everybody is going what's wrong with my
comment he's losing the locker room
Le'Veon bells on a jet ski Antonio
Browns not showing up for work and don't
get me started on Big Ben and that big
belly yeah that's really it okay the
Steelers need this game so much yeah
Ryan Fitzpatrick is feeling himself
DeSean Jackson's out there saying he's
the guy
the Buccaneers on prime time games in
their last 10 what's the record Sims
Buccaneers long time games what's the
record I'm gonna say its oh and 10 3 & 7
a.m.
Steelers primetime game what's their
record in the last 10 10 and 10 and oh
yeah I'm going with the Steelers yeah
Mike Tomlin angry team this the the
Buccaneers I respect them this is not
going to be a blowout by any means at
all but I'm getting the Steelers only
minus one which I get it's pretty much
to me the Steelers all they have to do
is win the game the Buccaneers have had
big play after big play and I look at
the Steelers I think they're gonna sit
back Ryan Fitzpatrick is not throwing
down the seams like Patrick mahomes is
it's not gonna be a monsoon like it was
for the Browns I think the Steelers
there's a chance Joe Haden comes back
I'm looking forward to that but I think
that Big Ben is gonna is gonna have a
lot of success throwing on the Bucks and
I think that Ryan Fitzpatrick does as
well but I think that the Steelers and
the words of Sims call the Bucks Bluff
and makes them run and Payton Barmer
gets less than 60 yards rushing and
they're just lobbing it up to Mike Evans
I like the Steelers yeah yeah I'm with
you too I'm going to put $100 on the
Pittsburgh Steelers I mean this spreads
minus one I'm picking the Steelers to
win this game 34 to 24 okay that's a
pretty big way yeah I think it's I think
it's going to be a shootout I think the
Steelers of course like you've said are
going to be desperate I do think that
again you know this isn't Patrick
mahomes they're playing you know they
have some familiarity with this offense
too I'm not saying they have like a
direct knowledge of Dirk cutter but I'm
just saying with Andy Reid and Patrick
mahomes everybody's still trying to
figure out what the hell they're gonna
do on a weekly basis it's new to the
league because mahomes can do the full
scope of the Andy Reid offense plus his
arm is that special to where it's gonna
be a few more weeks to where everyone
starts to go okay they have some
tendencies here and there and all that
excuse me Tampa Bay is gonna be lit on
money it will Dungy Verta in the room
but Joe Hayden being back and I do think
at the end of the day that Mike Tomlin
and company on the defense side of the
ball are smart enough to go man I don't
think the Tampa Bay Buccaneers can run
the football and they will call their
bluff and I just don't see how how the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers can stop the pass
game of the Pittsburgh Steelers I think
it's kind of close for a while I mean it
could be 24 21 Tampa Bay but I just
think at the ends at the end of the day
I think reality is going to set in where
Big Ben will kick some ass and I think
Fitzpatrick makes one maybe two bad
mistakes in the second half Steelers
13424
all right guys that's it for the game so
just to recap here games that you guys
disagreed on Thursday Night Football
Sims went with the Browns left go you
went with the Jets and I can make some
more money for a Saints Falcons Sims
went with the Saints left go went with
the Falcons moving on down the line here
Oakland at Miami Sims you went with
Miami left go goes with the oh and to
Oakland Raiders this isn't safe
Cincinnati when you re saying I don't
like Cincinnati at Carolina Sims went
with the Bengals left go you went with
the Panthers Tennessee at the well and
the one thing that's happening that I'm
noticing ok so you've gone home team and
then I went away then I went home you
went away and then I went away you and
Bert we have not no consistency all
right Tennessee at Jacksonville Sims
went with the Titans plus six and a half
let's go when Jaguars minus six and a
half moving on down here someone I'm
probably scared of that Sims go with the
49ers plus six and a half left go you
went with KC and really like I really
like your pic there and then that's what
I kind of want to steal the last
disagreement Dallas we're best football
friends
sim is wearing with Dallas plus one and
a half left go took the Seahawks in that
game all right let me read I have five
games that I have checked for left Cole
ox I have to do this for Sunday of
course Sims left go listener so you get
the little sneak peek I'm gonna read my
five yeah which one should I be most
confident in okay Green Bay minus three
at Washington okay
Chargers plus seven at Rams
Minnesota - 16 and a half against
Buffalo okay so far just let stop right
there the only one I would doubt is
Green Bay at Washington okay I think
they're gonna win the game but they
could be down by six with a middle right
now you like Chargers in Minnesota more
than Green Bay I do
Chicago - six and Arizona I like your
Vikings over the bills yes that's right
Chicago - six in Arizona yeah and New
England - seven at Detroit
so you think get rid of Green Bay it
just it feet of me like I I don't know
there's just a part of me that yeah that
game you know what that means that means
that I have one game at one o'clock and
I'm sitting there all day worried about
my fours at my eight right which is
actually not bad for social media cuz
they might forget about me by then yeah
you won't let them forget so so you're
thinking and I agree cuz I already
picked these Minnesota - sixteen and a
half
Chargers plus seven Chicago - six New
England - seven I'm picking three teams
I'm picking against if you look at that
Buffalo Arizona and Detroit to pick four
or five I have to before but I'm picking
against Buffalo Arizona and Detroit
which is always good to be against those
team yeah and then I'm thinking the
Chargers are gonna keep it close yeah
alright alright before we do GTL we just
got a DM from longtime Express Sam
Cassell as' and he just said I wanted to
send you a picture from my Madden game I
signed Matt Simms to the Jags and cut
bortles Matt threw for 400 yards and
eight touchdowns in his first game 77.7
completion great job Matt let it go Matt
we're gonna do it Matt's 97 on my list
so he is outperformed number seven uh ya
know GTL left gone for Matt I need to
you have my text it to you
alright I got my phone on silent in Week
one Sims got a lot of nonsense from
people saying he's not good at picking
guaranteed to lose week two he went out
there and he went four and one the only
game he got wrong was Kansas City beat
the Steelers we'll see if he learned his
lesson I mean I'll stop pickin into
Patrick Mahone
okay also I
let me just write these down real quick
okay can we cut out the minutiae no shut
your mouth hold on I just want to make
sure I write all their matchups right
and just as this flows nicely okay so
hold on he learns minutiae and now he's
saying it all the time can't quantify my
my English language speaking my
vocabulary cannot be quantified it's a
special gift that I had I'd like you to
start using extracurriculars
extracurriculars I like that I didn't
bring this up while we were taping
because I didn't want to throw off the
flow you you said during the Cardinals
breakdown I'll see it when I believe it
which is not the phrase I'll believe
thank you what do you mean you didn't
bring it up
I just how you do already had an
argument and are you ready to go here
I'm almost hold on I'm writing some
stuff down so this goes well okay hold
on one second I just want to make sure I
mean I've only got nine jobs and 95
million things to worry about sorry I
didn't take care of GTL and damn have
these people watched me on GTL the last
two years I dominate this crap I mean
last year it was like not even fun for a
while I went like five and oh so many
weeks in a row I was like damn this is
boring I'm like the Patriots like I just
end up with my Super Bowl it sounds like
a no in five weeks all right I is ready
you wait for it he delivers it's
guaranteed to lose ETL it's not gym tan
laundry it's guaranteed to lose shins
where are we starting oh let go
we're starting in Buffalo because the
Bills stink and I think they're the
worst team in football and Minnesota is
awesome at home Minnesota greater than
Buffalo and Vikings I've heard like to
kill bills so that's why I can't pick
that chirp chirp chirp
bring me your nuts the Cardinals are
next oh that is a smart little bear
Cardinals you are the second worst team
in football behind the bills and the
Bears defense is way too much for that
crappy offense out there in Arizona
left cause mama Sharon said you're gonna
lose left coast daddy
Bruce says you're gonna lose and
vendrick's in law said you're gonna lose
- it's a triple whammy on that one
guaranteed to lose rolls on Simms what
happens when a coach that coach for
Bella cheque moves on what happens when
they face each other they lose cuz
nobody out thinks Bill Belichick hey
Lions sorry you're going to lose because
it's Boston and Tommy's coming to town
and he's extra angry because he lost to
a Jaguar last week he's not gonna lose
to two cats in a row that ain't happenin
sorry my momma Dirty Diana Sims told me
that that's why I'm going with it thanks
Dirty Diana are the next one it's very
rare that a team that's never lost is on
guaranteed to lose but Sims shocked
their brain but damn it's a hard week
and I don't know where else to go on
this one so I gotta go with them Broncos
they're gonna lose to the Ravens on the
road I almost screwed up that part but
the Ravens are gonna be mad they're
angry the Raven is coming guaranteed to
lose it's a battle of oh and two teams
you're trusting a team to win that
hasn't won Sims I'm fearing for your
life who you pickin well the Giants are
gonna lose sorry I mean it's
unimpressive - Shaun worth Watson verse
don't hit me
so I can't pick don't hit me Eli Manning
in this matchup I'm not that stupid
sorry I got to seize it so believes it
and you know who I left off this list
this is the week but lights will be free
for everyone and they shall poorest
dilly dilly Cleveland dilly dilly and
that was guaranteed to lose don't forget
to have your dogs spayed or neutered
all of our set has been provided by
Dillard's Dillard's fashion for the
south
Thank You captain stock all right wow
that is hard
how'd that go you think your in-laws
would be okay with yeah they'll be good
okay when are we gonna start figuring
out what these teams are like two more
weeks
you think so yeah I think when we get to
like week five yeah yeah it's hard this
is oh it's the hardest year ever because
of what we talked about to start the
year the preseason is a different animal
this year you don't see schemes people
are scared to play their players and
it's really hard I thought this year to
get a feel for football teams of what
they're trying to accomplish more this
year than ever before
alright those are our picks maybe I
think Fenric is gonna maybe post a
graphic if you guys want to post what do
you want to post it on Twitter yeah well
post on Twitter we'll just of all our
picks and where we stand on all that
stuff if you guys want to see our picks
for your picks
you heard Sims is guaranteed to lose
enjoy the games follow us on social at
Sims and left go Instagram we've been
trying to post a lot Twitter especially
a lot on game day but Sunday morning
she'll have left coast locks you'll have
Sims and 60 and we're gonna put up a
schedule of all the games that we kind
of want to make that like our little
comment for thread so if you guys want
to talk to each other we'll do it there
call for Sims peace out homies or Fenric
good evening and for the lef koe man
hope my pics are right and since pics
are wrong holla holla holla holla holla
joy week 3 catch you later
peace
[Music]
you